lo cierto es que falta menos de una hora
para que arranque esa edición número 93
de los premios oscar en unas condiciones
atípicas por la pandemia de el
coronavirus sin embargo los
organizadores quieren que sea una
ceremonia completamente normal o lo más
normal posible por eso se ha pedido que
esa gala sea completamente presencial se
ha prohibido que las celebridades
aparezcan por videoconferencia y además
se va se está permitiendo que los
invitados aparezcan sin mascarilla
durante mientras estén frente a las
cámaras eso sí la academia ha dicho que
quiere se están asegurando que están
funcionando todos los protocolos de
sanidad para evitar cualquier foco de
contagio
este año va a haber como novedad por un
lado se va a dividir la ceremonia en
tres cuatro partes por un lado en este
lugar emblemático el teatro dolby de la
ciudad de los ángeles se van a acoger
las principales actuaciones musicales y
luego está la estación de los ángeles
allí es donde se ha organizado una
pequeña alfombra roja
con pocas personalidades y la
organización ha pensado en los nominados
que están en europa y que no pueden
viajar por las reacciones desde el
coronavirus por eso ha puesto dos sedes
una en parís y otra en londres para que
puedan disfrutar igualmente de la
ceremonia de esta noche
antonio algunos los nombres de películas
y actores y empiezan a sonar como
favoritos pero cuáles son las
expectativas
y lo cierto es que será la edición más
diversa eso es lo que dicen los expertos
del séptimo arte básicamente porque hay
nueve actores de origen étnico que están
nominados en la favorita aparentemente
es normar land de la directora chloe es
out ella junto a emera el canal de
marketing young woman son las únicas dos
mujeres que están nominadas las primeras
dos mujeres en la historia que están
nominadas en la categoría de mejor
dirección eso sí va a ser una ceremonia
bastante reivindicativa ya que muchos
habían criticado la falta de diversidad
que hay en el séptimo arte especialmente
en la industria de hollywood y por
ejemplo tenemos en el caso de viola
davis que está nominada es la actriz
negra con más nominaciones de toda la
historia tiene cuatro nominaciones y
ella en más de una ocasión ha criticado
esa falta de oportunidades que tiene la
comunidad afroamericana en la industria
del cine también se espera un sentido
homenaje
al actor chadwick bousman conocido por
su papel de black panther en la pantera
negra él falleció hace unos meses a los
43 años a causa de un cáncer y se le
podría dar el premio póstumo a mejor
actor y para terminar tenemos a anthony
hopkins que también se ha convertido en
el actor de mayor edad
vietnam opta a un premio a como mejor
actor por la película the fighter el
padre el comparte además el reparto con
la actriz olivia colman que también está
nominada a mejor actriz de reparto así
que estamos todos muy pendientes de
cuando arranque esta ceremonia aquí en
la ciudad de los ángeles en unas
condiciones atípicas y vamos a ver qué
nos depara esta noche desde aquí desde
desde hollywood